you felt when those three guys were all
together they had bonded somehow that
was the wise album Brian that's where
you walked out of the beat i well know I
only went out because I did feel like it
was you know we don't happen and that
was fine and we were trying to be a band
again which I love
right and and I'm looking oh I'm there
in the studio and it's like I I don't
feel good I don't feel part of it so I
go and knock on John's door and I say
hey you know I just don't feel right I
don't feel it you know I'm part of this
you three seems so close to knee goes I
thought it was you three right so I said
okay are going knock on Paul's door and
I tell them the same thing and you know
I don't feel part of this I feel you
three are so close knee goes I thought
it was you three right so is it [ __ ]
I'm off yeah it's that part of the
horror of being in the great part of
being in a band is you have your mates
and you know I love it right man I'll
always have but the worst is the
paranoia and fear well you don't have it
every day
and you know the great thing you know
then I came back and they were sending
faxes to me come on home right and
George at the studio full of flowers
that was great and and then we did you
have Blues in a room about a foot square
like this rock band again so we said we
started playing more like a band after
the downtime we had onthe you know
putting orchestras on and trumpet
players